john connery the actor of course most
famously known for playing
james bond in dr no has sadly died at
the age of
90. former first minister of scotland
alex salmond who is a good friend of sir
sean connery's released a statement
reading
the world's greatest scot the last of
the real hollywood stars the definitive
bond
sean connery was all of these things but
much more
he was also a staunch patriot a deep
thinker and outstanding human being i've
had the rare privilege of being his
friend
for more than 30 years and enjoyed every
single moment of his company and talk
sean was determined throne of scots
would say but only about things he
really believed in his charity the
scottish international education trust
has over the years supported thousands
of youngsters with a helping hand in
their education
sean was largely self-taught and this
gave him an abiding belief in the value
of education which he put into action
through that trust his support for
scottish independence was unshakable and
started long before it was fashionable
it made him a political target for many
who would otherwise have formed over him
but he shrugged it off knowing that he
was a much bigger person than any of his
detractors
he was honest and brave and it has been
one of the privileges of my life to
count him as a friend
his sense of irony and humor were
legendary as was his love of country
scotland forever wasn't just tattooed on
his forearm but was imprinted on his
soul
he was a great and gentle man
condolences to his wife
micheline his sons jason and stefan his
brother neil
and all of the family that a statement
by the former first minister of scotland
alex salmond on the death of sir sean
connery at the
age of 90.